notre invité du samedi 20 heures ce soir
sophie la part
sophie dakar vous êtes aide soignante
vous étiez employée dans une maison de
retraite réputé de l'île de france mais
devant les soins bâcler les
manipulations brutale et l'absence
d'humanité imposé par la rentabilité de
l'entreprise
vous avez préféré démissionner on en
parle à 20 heures
[Musique]
sophie re bonsoir vous avez 48 ans vous
êtes maire de cinq filles âgées de 13 à
20 ans l'envi d'avoir une famille
nombreuse toujours correspondu à votre
soif de données et de partager ce qui
explique votre idée de soigner des
personnes âgées pour vous souhaiter une
évidence avec un élément moteur qui est
encore l'amour que je porte à mes
grands-parents
qui mais quand parents vieillissants
sont trouve éloigné de moi ils se sont
beaucoup plus occupé de moi lorsque
j'étais enfant lorsque j'étais jeune et
je n'ai pas pu leur rentrer en retour ce
que j'aurais aimé faire pour eux à ce
moment là donc ça a été je pense aussi
l'élément à la base déclenchant alors en
2003 vos filles sont grandes et vous
entrez dans une association vous
commencez à faire des soins à domicile
en parallèle de suivi une formation de
psychologie soins palliatifs comment
traiter les malades atteints de
parkinson d'alzheimer
et cette expérience d'être soignante est
un rêve en fait plus qu'un travail car
vous accomplissez votre vocation c'est
un un milieu professionnel où je me
révèle complètement et je dis ce que les
malades d les mourants m'ont appris à
vivre autrement quand on approche de la
mort on quitte le paraître pour l'être
s'y attendre la fin de vie c'est pour
moi un temps où on n'est jamais plus
dans la vie qu'à ce moment là c'est
vraiment un espace des vérités leur zone
technique c'est vous dit prendre la
météo de vos patients c'est à dire quand
vous arrivez vous les regardez vous
regardez leur regard leur comportement
leur mouvement et vous arrivez à voir
tout de suite dans quel état ils sont
quoi surtout lorsque nous sommes en
place en soins avec des personnes qui
n'ont plus les moyens de communiquer
donc dans les situations du langage ce
qu'on appelle la communication non
verbale est donc ce que j'appelle ma
météo c'est tous ces petits signes qui
font de permettre de voir comment ils ou
elles par la façon dont ils respirent la
façon dont il me regarde ce matin
l'auteur qu'il ya dans la chambre tous
c'est petit tous ces petits signes qui
sont extrêmement importantes pour nous
autres soignants alors il ya des
histoires bouleversantes de votre époque
d'aide-soignante à domicile
marcel qui veut sortir une dernière fois
pour aller acheter du pain au village
alors ça lui prend quand même temps pour
pour remarcher pour sortir quoi ça fait
à peu près 24 - qu'est-ce que sultan qui
n'a plus quitté son domicile
insuffisance respiratoire à ce que l'on
voit iran et en collaboration avec le
kiné nous commençons un travail de
stimulation et c'est vrai qu'après
après huit mois marcel et près de mon
point de vue à pouvoir sortir et donc sa
dernière sortie c'est d'aller justement
accompagné à mon bras jusqu'à la
boulangerie où tous ses anciens copains
vont sortir tout le monde va le
féliciter et l'encourager
c'est magnifique c'est les gens du
village applaudissent quoi ces
caisses comme un film et c'est ce
qu'elles sont vides la shna demain et
pour lui c'était vraiment une poète il
ya gens aussi qui est atteint d'un
cancer en phase terminale et dont le
rêve est de danser la valse une dernière
fois et il le fera avec la perfusion
dans le bras c'est un effort pour lui il
a très envie de cela et oui c'est aussi
un grand moment ouais alors au bout de
quatre on voulait tenter une nouvelle
expérience et travailler dans une maison
de retraite scène où vous entre est un
établissement haut de gamme répertorié
parmi les meilleurs d'île de france
c'est quand même le prix minimum j'ai
quand même 3000 euros par mois ça va
jusqu'à plus de 5000 euros par mois la
publicité dit c'est une résidence
chaleureuse et familiale au coeur d'un
parc boisé voilà mais dès que vous
arrivez là bas à une collègue vous
avertis vous dit si tu sais on n'a même
pas le temps d'aller aux toilettes quoi
le rythmé et très rapide par exemple
soir vous avez une heure pour ramener du
réfectoire et coo chez 9 patients et il
est évident que en 60 minutes mais on ne
peut pas être au mieux dans la relation
de soin et bien traitant pour installer
neuf personnes extrêmement dépendant
pour la nuit alors six aides soignantes
pour cinquante et une chambre l'avait
pas le temps de prendre la météo comme
vous dites
alors résultat évidemment pas de
toilettes approfondie les soins de
bouche jamais fait les pieds pas lavé
des fauteuils plein de débris
alimentaires donc pas désinfectée il est
vrai que nous retrouvons souvent des
prises de médicaments sous les fauteuils
sous les assises de fauteuils les
fauteuils ne sont pas quotidiennement
désinfecter comme il ne te ferai les
patients sont souvent reconduit en
chambre toujours avec des prix
alimentaires on peut même les retrouver
installé au lit à certains moments avec
tt prix alimentaires je dirais que cela
touche essentiellement je tiens à le
préciser les plus démunis c'est ce qu'on
appelle la maltraitance institutionnelle
et vous vous élevez contre cette
terminologie d'un seul coup c'est une
façon de la dnat de la nommer à force tu
tires maltraitance institutionnelle
j'ai l'impression qu'on va finir par
croire et vouloir entendre que c'est
normal ce qui n'est pas et ce qui n'est
pas acceptable
monsieur alors vous raconter des choses
hallucinantes maurice amputé des deux
jambes
cicatrices infectés à la hanche qui a
des escarres parce qu'il est dans son
lit depuis des années et qui baigne dans
son urine parce que sa sonde urinaire
n'a pas été changée depuis six mois et
donc il va falloir exactement douze
jours aucune nouvelle sonde nous arrive
et qu'elle puisse être remplacé tout sûr
c'est énorme
or jacques 75 ans alors lui
pour remplir les lions l'install à côté
d'une chambre où il ya une femme qui
auraient toutes les nuits
lui il dit mais attendez je paye quoi je
voulais être dans une autre chambre je
vais pouvoir dormir et on lui dit que
c'est pas possible donc tout ça c'est
simplement pour montrer la difficulté à
vouloir faire cohabiter en maison de
retraite médicalisée des résidentes qui
sont parfois relativement en bonne santé
au milieu de résidence aux qui vont
poser ce genre de souci ça c'est toute
une problématique effectivement alors ce
qui est terrible c'est qu'un jour le
gall il dit je vais je vais dîner chez
mon fils il sort il va se jeter sous un
train
pour le pire c'est blanche si vous
racontiez passant le croirait pas dire
que cette femme est sur un fauteuil
roulant on l'amène à la table du goûter
est en fait la personne qui l'a amené à
la table du goûter s'est pas aperçue
qu'elle était morte
simplement pour montrer et je n'en veux
absolument pas à la collègue et peu
importe c'est que les conditions de
travail peuvent justement faire que
l'instant où cette personne était
descendu jusqu en salle à manger ça peut
prendre cinq minutes il n'y a pas eu un
regard pour m l'objectif est qu'ils de
rassembler très rapidement tous les
résidents pour le goûter voilà c'est
tout simplement ça et quand vous vous la
voyez vous lui parler elle bouge pas
l'avait toujours la tête un peu penché
comme ça donc au départ et vous
apercevez qu'elle est morte et vous
l'évacuer pour donner le change c'est
assez grand vous voulez allez venez je
vais vous ramenez chez dans la chambre
voilà
alors vous dites que quand on place ses
parents ou ses grands parents en maison
de retraite
la mauvaise conscience est telle qu'on
préfère s'aveugler c'est à dire on paye
voilà je paye 3000 4000 5000 euros par
mois et finalement ça évite d'une
certaine façon d'être rongé par la
culpabilité quoi lorsqu'un enfant
plaçons par an il ne peut pas avoir
bonne conscience le placement c'est
toujours un choix
extrêmement difficile pour la famille
donc forcément l'attitude de culpabilité
va faire que ils ont préféré et ils ont
raison quelque part nous faire confiance
et se convaincre que le parent est en
totale sécurité chez nous et ça on peut
le comprendre tout à fait on n'est
jamais bien quand on place
son papa ou de sa maman jamais
pourquoi finalement on fait pas plus
d'aigle à domicile parce que c'est mieux
pour les pour les vieux et en plus de ça
ça coûte moins cher
effectivement cela coûte moins cher
néanmoins il faut savoir que la
maltraitance existe également à domicile
le domicile n'est pas épargner
complètement des attitudes malveillantes
est ce qu'on peut dire que moins les
enfants viennent voir leurs parents plus
les parents sont maltraités
la porte est grande ouverte je dirais
oui oui parce que dès l'instant où on
sait qu'il y a de temps en temps une
visite on remarque facilement que vers
des résidents la famille et à ses
proches est impliqué justement le risque
est moindre mannequin de
tarik savez je pense que ce soit des
institutions ou à domicile au bout du
compte c'est le fond de la question
c'est est ce qu'on va vers une société
où avec les personnes âgées on considère
que comme elles sont plus utiles au
système bien on va investir de l'argent
pour s'en faire sur leur dos mais plus
s'occuper de la dignité elle a tout
c'est toutes ces histoires que j'entends
sont des idées des histoires de la
dignité et finalement je pense que c'est
vrai qu'une société et digne par la
façon dont elle est digne avec les
personnes les plus âgées ce qu'ils ont
fait est constitué je crois qu'on
devrait l'entendre très profondément
comme une vraie question philosophique
pas simplement que ma question comptable
il ya eu le regard que nous avons pour
nos anciens et on s'en est aperçu au
moment de la canicule de 2003 pas de
temps l'attitude du gouvernement plutôt
bons caf eu ce qu'ils pouvaient ce n'est
pas là mais on s'est rendu compte en
effet un certain nombre de vieux entre
guillemets été laissée comme on laisse
des chiens dans les stations-service et
ce regard là alors que vous avez des
sociétés comme les sociétés africaines
par exemple ou vraiment légende grippale
source et ils ont quand même ici
inimaginable que leurs anciens la mère
la grand-mère de l'arrière grand mère
soit abandonné donc elle elle meurt dans
la hutte où dans la cabane où dans la
maison voilà je pense que ça nous
interrogeons ça doit nous éclairer vous
avez parfaitement raison patrick georges
marc je serais d'accord avec monsieur
ramadan moins sur ce point une société
se juge l'amiante à trets et ses anciens
et c'est tout le système qui s'éclaire
de cette lumière ou de cette ombre et
c'est tout à fait effrayant
l'industrialisation des corps qui est un
peu préoccupantes et
pourquoi n'en parle pas plus de tout ça
parce que finalement c'est très rare les
témoignages là dessus parce que il y a
encore la loi du silence qui règne
autour de cela que la maltraitance
institutionnelle peut être considéré
comme quelque chose qui n'est pas
gravissime c'est vrai qu'il ya pire au
niveau de la maltraitance et je tiens
quand même à préciser que mon idée
n'était pas de dire ou de répéter
quelque chose que l'on sait déjà c'est
une prise de conscience de soignante un
devoir de citoyenne me semble-t-il c'est
ya un petit moment depuis le coeur de
l'été que j'avais vraiment envie de
témoigner et de dire non pas accuser
simplement de dire voilà ce que j'ai
vécu voilà ce qu'il se passe tout en
sachant que j'ai passé des moments
extraordinaires dans cette structure
c'était un plaisir de me rendre au
service ce jour en service de nuit très
sincèrement simplement il me manquait
il m'a manqué un petit peu quelqu'un
pour faire cela
et ce qui m'a mis vraiment en avance et
ma rencontre avec un ami françois nénin
qui est journaliste
d'investigation qui est très ce qui est
extrêmement sensibilisé au sujet et nous
qui a su gagner ma confiance et à partir
de là nous nous sommes mis au travail
tous les deux ça je tiens à le dire
c'était vraiment un travail de partage
en voilà sous l'article de vsd et d'où
le livre que je vous souhaite de publier
pour crier encore cela un peu plus fort
merci de votre pénale et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu